I will talk about a comical capacity
and many of us who who are here last
week
have seen a lot about comical capacity
in the medical testing weekend but let
me uh very quickly Define some uh basic
Solutions
so uh for string X where we want to load
the southeast encoding from which we can
recover X and the comic of capacity
of X is the minimum length of a string n
which we will call it a program such
that if you run the universal tune
machine on end we get back X
and the universe number between machine
is sexy in advance and there's slow
decision on how long the program will
run
so we can Define the time value version
of Chromebook of conversity
and uh
first we fix the time bound T and then
the T time bounded comic of complexity
is the minimum length of a string of a
program that can recover X within t
stats
and in this talk uh and this uh timer
conversation is stored as K sub squared
T and in this talk I would just say KT
to mean k superscript t
and the reason that I don't use skate
poly is because in some application
mentioned later the T doesn't have to be
uh polynomial
and recently there have been many
exciting applications of harmonicomical
capacity here I just did some of them in
uh average case capacity
photography and learning
and uh
capacity is very useful but there seem
to be some issues when we use KT as the
lotion of time under common capacity in
certain contexts
and one is that KT doesn't seem to be
very applicable in the randomized
setting and the second step we don't
have good understanding of the
fundamental properties of comic of
capacity for KT
and I will talk more about this later
but let me just say that uh to address
these issues my research like with my
collaborators
is about
um incorporating Randomness into Comic
of complexity
and try to make it more useful
and the lotion
that we'll focus on is called
probabilistic time boundary comical
capacity which was introduced in a drone
work with Haley Goldberg planting
cabinets and uh
and I have written down the technical
and empty and we call it tkt
and I've written down the formal
definition here but understanding this
definition is not so important for this
talk
and basically
um
uh we can think of it as if a string X
has more probabilistic combo of
complexity
then it means it has a short encoding
given a random string
and now let me show you some application
of tkt
and we
we will see how it can be used to
address the issues that I uh mentioned
for KT
and a couple years ago um
a had this great results about adding
average case capacity and he showed that
if MP can be efficiently solved on
average by deterministic algorithms
then we can solve up in determinist time
2 to the N divided by log n in the worst
case
and in his uh later work with mikito
larashima from the same assumption they
showed that we can learn small circuits
on any unknown PE poly samplerable
distributions I know that leader of
these results
says anything about common capacity but
the proofs heavily rely on
uh panel comic book of capacity and more
specifically KT
and in both cases we lead to
assume the MP can be uh solved on
average by determined algorithms and if
we
just assume that MP can be solved by a
randomized algorithm the proof no longer
work and the reasons that this result
the proofs long black box if we just
replace the average a determinist
average algorithm by uh
randomized average case algorithm
then we cannot just use as a bullet box
and get the same thing
so the question here is whether we can
extend it to the randomized setting
there are good reasons to consider a
randomized average case capacity and not
just the the domestic one but I will
lock that into the details
and in the Sandpaper where we introduced
the lotion of pkt
we also use this lotion to
extend the previous result to the
randomized setting so we show that if MP
can be efficiently solved on average by
randomized algorithm that we can still
get the faster algorithm
a faster randomized algorithm that
solves up
and we get we also get exactly this
learning consequence
as increased work
okay uh next I will
I'm going to talk about some some of the
very important properties of common
cough complexity and one such property
is called a coding fearing so the coding
theorem for time bounded comic book of
complexity says that if you have
computable distribution D that samples x
with probability of x
then the Chromebook of capacity of X is
at most log
1 over T of x
and the proof of the coding theorem
usually rise on the time unbounded
feature of Commonwealth capacity so the
question here is whether whether there's
a coding theorem for time bounded combo
of capacity say uh K poly
so if you want to show that this went to
low if there
if we have a efficiency sample of
voltage Improvement the samples x with
probability of X can visit at the K poly
capacity of X is at most log 1 over T of
x
foreign
this is true
if we assume a strong deep randomization
assumption but this result is
conditional
and you know join work with uh Eco level
and marvelous Siemens we get an
unconditional coding theorem for TK
quality so if there's an efficient
sample distribution T that samples x
with probability of X then we can say
that the PK poly capacity of X is at
most log
1 over T of x
and we can also show a Converse so um
the efficient sample ability of a string
correspond exactly to its PK poly
capacity yeah
and
okay another important property in
common of capacity is called symmetry of
information
so we load that for string X and Y
the comical capacitor of X and Y is
roughly at most common capacity of X
plus the chronicle of conversion of Y
gamma X and this is just because if we
want to get a program that brings X and
Y then we can first use the program that
brings X
and then use the program that prints y
given X
and see much of information for time and
bounded combo of capacity basically says
that this inequality
is tight in the sense that K of X and Y
is at least K of X Plus K of Y given x
minus some small term
and the reason why we call the symmetry
of information is because from the two
inequality we can get something
uh best analogous to what's called uh
simulation information in Shannon's
information Theory
and again the question here is uh does
signature formation hold in the time
boundary setting
say uh for KT
and unlike the coding theorem uh below
that symbol symmetry information is
unlikely to hold
for KT
and that's because uh we know that if
one-way function S6 then signature of
information for KT fails
and uh
intuitively if we if we have a wrong way
function f or let's say if you have a
wrong way permutation then from X we can
compute f of x efficiency but if we are
just given f of x we cannot get back X
efficiency
so that's an asymmetry of information
between these two strings if we take
into account the time
and longer than water label formally
connects the existence of firmware
function to the failure of symmetric
information for KT
but the results only shows
One Directions
and since then has been uh okay since
there has been an open question whether
we can get some if and only if statement
between one-way functions and symmetry
of information and yeah upcoming work
with uhara rahulango um
we showed that one-way function exists
if and only if
some average case version of C major
information for pkt does slot hold
so again pkt seems to be the right
lotion to connect the one-way function
and signature of information
and in the same paper we have we also
use other properties of
pkt to characterize
um more complexity assumptions such as
plot equals to MP or MP star on
average
and there will be a talk on this in the
upcoming Workshop of the medical
investing program
any questions
live questions so your new condition on
equivalence of one-way functions how
does it relate to the average case
hardness of ckt or something is it in
the same Spirit you mean the last one
yeah because there are some other
theorems like this right like the new
pass theorems and so on yeah first of
all yeah it's unconditional so the
equivalency and compared to leopards new
process that uh
from wave function is excess if like KT
some uh KT is hard on average
and in this case we are not considering
like the highest of computing some
problems we consider whether the
properties of pkt holes whether
properties of time management capacity
holds
and so sometimes it's like different
functions
that sounds like
are you so the question is what's the
what's the construction the arrow going
the other way so if you assume the
Symmetry fails then how do you is there
a simple way to describe the one wave
function construct
maybe you can take it offline yeah
right so let's uh take a coffee break
now and we'll resume at 11 30 and let's
thank all the speakers
[Applause]